all right we have new information this
morning on two more cyber attacks
targeting
new york city's subway system and a
ferry service for summer resorts in
massachusetts
this follows this week's attack on a
giant meat processing company
that owns dozens of u.s brands jeff
begues reports now on the growing
pressure
for the u.s to strike back less than two
weeks from a summit with russian
president vladimir putin
the white house says that all
retaliatory options are on the table
mr president will you retaliate against
russia for this latest ransomware attack
we're looking closely at that issue meat
processing company
jbs is trying to get fully up and
running after the cyber attack
which the fbi attributed to a
russia-linked ransomware operation known
as
our evil the fbi says agents are working
diligently to bring the threat actors to
justice
the hack follows the ransomware attack
last month on colonial pipeline
which led to the shutdown of the largest
u.s fuel pipeline and sparked panic
buying at gas stations
another ransomware attack wednesday hit
massachusetts steamship authority
which runs ferries to nantucket and
martha's vineyard
and the new york subway system confirmed
that it suffered a cyber attack in april
the new york times reports the hack was
linked to chinese hackers but the damage
was contained
there's really no preferred sector or
segment of the economy
of these ransomware actors chris krebs
is the former director of the cyber
security and infrastructure security
agency
what is happening in the world that u.s
companies
us government entities are such
popular targets for these hackers you
know the unfortunate reality is that
ransomware is a business and business is
good
and until we can uh disrupt the
profitability of the ransomware
business model these events are going to
continue to happen
our evil the prime suspect in the jbs
attack is believed to have stolen
hundreds of millions of dollars over the
years
jbs is expected to resume production at
all of its u.s facilities
anthony jeff begaye is in washington d.c
thanks